this is a cloud architect they're trying
to establish the right organizational
patterns for building and deploying web
apps using public Cloud infrastructure
to do that they ask du for help and look
to pick the right compute option that
will be fully managed after looking at
the option suggested they decide to
focus on cloud run but what's the best
way to make sure it can scale duet AI to
the rescue once more being new to Cloud
run the architect gets more help from
duet on networking and authentication
help they will also need caching to help
with scale so duet AI can give advice on
caching options and manage services like
memory store the web app will also need
a database layer and for that there's a
few options in Cloud the architect asks
for recommendations and set on cloud
sequel finally it's time to deploy all
three tiers duet AI shares a sample
architecture that includes Cloud run
memory store and Cloud sequel all
working happily together pleased as pie
our architect is ready to test it out
hooray with all that time they saved
getting this architecture spun up the
cloud architect has more time to
practice her ballet moves
what will you
[Music]
build